is it a little shady in here or is it  just us he's cool so I don't like you  the 2017 MTV Video Music Awards were  packed with powerful moments but there  was also a healthy amount of shade  another day another drama drama Taylor  Swift debuted the music video for her  new single look what you made me do and  it seems to take aim at her famous  frenemies Kim Kardashian Kanye West Katy  Perry and even herself you are so fake  oh there she goes playing the victim  - speaking of Katy ears perked up after  she made this comment while catching a  viewers who switched over from the Game  of Thrones finale  Kendrick Lamar on fire and Sharons  friends dead it could have been a  reference to Ed Sheeran's performance  with lil Uzi vert but it also could have  been a reference to this she's dead  there were some couch critics Adam  Levine and wife Behati Prinsloo tweeted  their jabs from home and fifth harmony  made it crystal clear they're just fine  without Camila Cabello  [Applause]